8 news now i-team has been investigating
problems inside prisons vanessa murphy
here with more of some of the key points
from this department of corrections
audit that the i-team obtained vanessa
denise and brian the audit points out
many claims about use of force inside
prisons are not being investigated this
could be an inmate reporting a claim
against an officer or vice versa several
different scenarios fit into that
category the audit also points to a lack
of training with firearms tasers even a
restraint chair and a 25 percent job
vacancy rate and the audit states use of
force data collected by the department
is inaccurate incomplete and unreliable
the audit says the department needs to
shape up to ensure prisons are safe and
humane it came up with 16
recommendations and provided examples
like out of a sample of 20 reports
alleging excessive use of force there
was no evidence the inspector general's
office even looked at them and after an
officer fired a blank round from a
shotgun during a use of force incident
there was no evidence he had up-to-date
training in a letter the n-d-o-c
director stated changes would be made in
response to that legislative council
bureau's audit when i interviewed
governor steve sisilak in january i
brought up issues about this lack of
transparency do you think the doc needs
to be more transparent and are you doing
anything about it well we try to be as
transparent as we possibly can i would
encourage all of my departments to be as
transparent as we can they're subject to
the same rules and regulations that all
state agencies are and the public has a
right to know what's going on because
someone's incarcerated doesn't take away
all their rights
a prison spokesman did reach out to me
after that interview with the governor
we are still working to get information
about various issues though and just
today the department denied one of our
requests we have more information about
that audit at 8newsnow.com from the
i-team's david charns